[Music]
foreign
host today let's go we're gonna be
talking about the Super Mario Brothers
movie Wahoo and I have Wendy Lee zany
here today she is our expert and we are
going to be deep diving into the movie
and breaking down
all of those Easter eggs all the things
in the movie all the things and uh
answering some of the questions that the
film Left Behind which is where is it
going to go from here because we know
it's going to go somewhere for here
because the box office was crazy like it
was a such a powered up box office so
first of all before we go any further we
have to warn you this is a
spoiler-filled episode so if you've not
seen the Super Mario Brothers movie
go play your games go watch a movie
a lot of galaxies
they're all counting on us hello
pressure Wendy welcome thank you thank
you so much for having me you know it's
funny we got to see this movie together
yeah so it's kind of serendipitous it's
very serendipitous we got to be here we
get to be here and talk about this movie
I had so much fun with this one and you
know what's funny is when they announced
it I was like initial reaction was yes
so excited and then went oh no because
then my the next thing my mind went to
is the quote-unquote video game movie
Curse right yeah and you're like can
they handle Mario well because Mario is
so iconic and really really important to
a lot of people it's got a lot of fans
Not Just Like Statewide but
internationally yeah so I was like can
they do it well and I remember watching
the first trailer and it was so vibrant
getting to look at the Mushroom Kingdom
right
oh okay I have a good feeling about this
one yeah well you know it's because well
first let's go into it and then we can
sort of talk about sort of
you know this craziness between and
people have been tweeting about it the
Tomato Meter score for this movie
56 currently the audience score
96 so you know it's just it's so crazy
because you and I did see this movie
together and I text you afterwards
and we were both like that was great
yeah and when I was watching it I'm
always and I actually think the video
game curse is over I agree I think for
the last few years I mean I think Sonic
had a lot to do with it detective
Pikachu I think the last I think yeah
The Last of Us oh my gosh the last one
but in terms of yeah especially animated
I don't know I just think they've been
doing a great job and I feel like those
days are over and I think what shocked
me is when I was watching it I kind of
sometimes when it's a beloved IP when
it's something so beloved I'm watching
it going please don't screw something up
please don't screw something up and so
I'm every single beat and every single
world that we went into I was like check
they did it check they did it and I
walked out thinking okay this is great
I'm thinking I'm guessing maybe the
score is gonna be like 80s 85 maybe and
I was
stunned my jaw hit the floor yeah when I
saw it I was like oh it's you know
embargo day excited and I like log on to
you know my Rotten Tomato and I was like
uh
so what do you think that was like I
mean I think it's obvious why people
love this movie I think the one thing
that surprised me about it and I think I
might have said this to you is it skewed
younger than I thought but that was
brilliant because I have friends that
have young kids and they don't play the
games they don't know the you know but
when you are going to do illumination
that kind of thing the older people I
thought it was maybe going to be like
kind of skewed for more like young teens
maybe that age range or like a Marvel
movie kind of thing
um but they would have alienated so so
many kids and from the reaction that I'm
getting from gamers
but people who you know know every
single version of Mario they feel
like
they did the they were I've never I
didn't hear one person say it's Gucci
young everybody seems to have enjoyed it
yeah it's a really fun like all ages all
family film you don't have to feel bad
about taking your youngest one because
you're worried about you know something
that's a little bit too much for them to
handle on screen it's bright it's
colorful but when we say skew young it's
not like oh they babied the movie they
didn't do that to any of the characters
like Bowser is just super mean you know
kidnapping the print not well he didn't
kidnap the princess in this one but
we'll get to that in a little bit but
you know it's getting over the ice
castle and and things like that so it
wasn't so like dumbed down to be like oh
it's like a kid joke it wasn't like
there are yes skewing young as in like
it's friendly for if you are if you have
you know a kid who's like five or six
maybe a little bit too young to be
playing a Mario game
um because they probably don't even
understand that's me now but they can
still go in and be like oh I get it I
enjoy and I enjoy the colors and the
sounds and the characters yeah so but I
don't know if that do you think that's
what the part of the reasons why I
affected the score I think so I there
are certain because I went through I
actually went through Rotten Tomatoes
and I was looking at sort of lately
what's been happening with superhero
movies animated films game you know IP
and I'm looking at like Shazam Fury the
gods 50 Rotten Tomatoes score 86
audience score Venom another sort of fun
yeah 57 Rotten Tomatoes score 84
quantumania 47 versus 83 Super Pets is a
little closer DC Super Pets that was fun
not a video game movie but you know 72
and 88 that was a little closer and you
know I am seeing I am seeing a trend so
do you think that what do you think that
is because I'm I'm thinking maybe it has
something to do with but see this is why
Super Mario confused me because I
thought I can kind of understand why
people are you know DC and Marvel and
people are upset or they're not agreeing
with what's going on but I thought this
was just a no-brainer but this was just
going to be higher this one so to speak
some of the other movies the examples
you were bringing up I hesitate to say
superhero fatigue because I don't really
believe in it yeah however there was a
lot of
all of it at once
from both you know
um comic book IPS so I so I wonder if
that's of that plays into effect I've
enjoyed all those movies like do I think
some of the previous ones have been
better on this and that yes but you have
to look at it individually I try not to
compare one movie to the next because
they're not all in the same they're not
interchangeable right but for Mario I
I feel like maybe
some wanted more of an arc to the
characters perhaps for Mario for Luigi
and for Bowser which I I guess you can
make the argument that like maybe the
story was a little bit on the thinner
side it didn't bother me at all I didn't
for me personally I wasn't going into
um Super Mario movie looking for the
arcs of this and the development of that
because it's Mario you play the game you
grew up with it so you understand the
concept of Mario and I think they did
give us a nice cute story of Mario doing
his thing and the interactions were true
you know between like Mario and Bowser
Bowser and Peach and with Donkey Kong
Etc so I feel like that maybe have one
of another one and this is again not a
complaint of mine but I'm just trying to
think outside of my own feelings
is maybe they felt that it was too full
of
game references but at the same time
then what else could there be right
because it's Mario movie so on the one
hand if you don't put it in people are
going to be like why couldn't you put it
in there because it's about Mario which
is a video game it's not a comic book
character it's not a manga character
it's Mario
um and I wonder if like oh it's too much
like it was exhausting for me it was and
I could have taken more like a little
home will be essentially was but I was
like yes one of the few movies I feel
like so many movies are too long now
this is the first hour 30 some odd
minutes I wanted more I think because
they spent a good amount of time
in Brooklyn before we even got to the
Mushroom Kingdom and at one point I was
getting nervous I'm like I know this
movie's only I knew how long it was
going into and I was a little nervous I
thought oh my gosh
you're spending a lot of time with them
plumbing and the dog like this is not
Super Mario it was making me nervous I
thought this is gonna be the third of
the movie and then we're not gonna get
so I feel like we could have given that
they did spend a lot of time in Brooklyn
they could have given us a little bit
more time in the Mushroom Kingdom
Because by the time we got to the end
when we went back to Brooklyn I was like
oh no no I'm not ready yet I'm not ready
to go back to Brooklyn but it was
actually I think a good creative choice
because I think someone pointed out and
I forget who pointed out I would give
them a credit but it was a very good
point that you wouldn't have seen first
of all you don't want to see the
Mushroom Kingdom destroyed yes the
destruction of buildings and this and
that I think it's easier to animate yeah
and easier to sort of see the fighting
scenes and animate the fighting scenes
if there's buildings and blocks and
streets and that kind of thing and
Visually it worked better yeah and I
like what you said about
taking the time in the first portion of
the movie to establish Mario and Luigi
in Brooklyn their home and that that's
your basis right there for the people
who wanted like the arc and the
development you see Mario and it's you
know they have this like cute commercial
to promote their business their
entrepreneurs right they're gonna go and
do their Plumbing thing and then you
have the family expectation and
generationally too because there was a
whole family vibe there and I actually
loved seeing that and I was like well
that's the basis for Mario and if the
big brother and he keeps trying and
trying trying doesn't give up and does
everything for his family and his for
his brother and that's why he kept going
so there was the reasoning for all of
that that's your base right there and
the arc it kind of almost come full
circle towards the end you know where he
essentially saves the world yeah you
know from from Bowser or Elise Brooklyn
um so I I enjoyed the full little circle
it's very slight but it didn't need to
be so so heavy it's illumination film so
I I like what they did and I like that
they brought it back into because now
into Brooklyn because now the situation
it's a lot more dire than just this
mushroom cream that nobody else in this
other world knew existed so it was only
the citizens and the Toads that was like
oh my gosh our kingdom and I love this
world but you bring it into Brooklyn
yeah and it's real world it's like oh no
how do we fix this uh what was his name
Spike Maniscalco so brilliant oh my God
and that was a good full circle moment
too yeah and he comes back and he sort
of Mario proves but I think you you know
you make a really good point about
I think setting up the story correctly
was a smart choice and you made me think
of something the Mario games you're
don't hate me Mario Gamers but the
worlds and all the versions of Mario are
the appeal it's not that you have this
long drawn out story about why he's
doing this or that and there are stories
within the games obviously between
Bowser and Peach you know they all have
their own little sub story but they were
smart enough to make it about the world
yeah but the story was great the story
was fine and exactly can you imagine if
they tried to make it super complicated
and then didn't give you all the Easter
eggs or the references we would all be
criticizing it exactly exactly we would
have hated it that's exactly right so
who is your favorite if you couldn't
choose who's your favorite voice
character because
I there was so much talk about Chris
Pratt being cast as Mario and people
were super upset and I thought was
really adorable in the beginning when
they do the commercial which was a
reference to way back yes when they do
the commercial and then at the very end
of the commercial they say did we get
the voices right because they put on the
accent for the commercial because they
thought that was sort of their you know
that was their stage yeah sort of their
stage personas yeah that that made the
voices work but
the thing for me was Mario being likable
and having that everybody's sort of
talking about their favorite Easter eggs
and that but I think what they got the
most right that made me love the movie
is there you cannot tell me there's a
person out there that didn't like Mario
as a character oh yeah like Mar they did
such a good job of making him that guy
in the movie that there was nothing
about him that anybody because it was
kind of irritated me or is this and
nobody can say anything about like they
did have characters at their job
and Chris Pratt is such an underrated
voice actor he is so good and I
encourage everybody if you've never done
this when he did Lego they showed him in
the recording booth there's a YouTube
video of him in the recording booth and
I was like
the things he can do with his voice and
watching his session was phenomenal wow
I kind of wanted to see him explore that
range though
in within the movie within the movies
that he that with the project that he'll
take on right moving forward like I'd
love to see that because it's it's I
think I saw another interview I can't
remember who it was that did it but it's
it was clear that the man could
replicate the Mario the original voice
he could he could do it and the thing is
that do we need that for like an hour
and a half could you do it for an hour
and a half probably not because in the
game Mario doesn't carry on a full
monologue ever in that voice you know we
get the iconic Wahoo let's go and and
this and that so I thought the
commercial aspect of it top of the movie
yeah so smart it explains the voice then
we can just move on it's like got it
check let's just move on and he still
gave us sprinkles of Mario but in at the
same time like can you imagine yeah and
I don't know how an entire movie would
sound with that voice but he does kind
of have to represent everybody and you
have to feel like
um this is some somebody that you can
sit with for a few hours yeah like if
you talk like that he would be very it
would be very specific yes and it would
be harder to just tell the story it
could be a little bit distracting but
yeah and he clearly could make do the
sounds and do all that and I was like
well played Chris Pratt that in
interviews he started doing it yeah
one of them that somebody I can't
remember who it was that he just like oh
I go sound like this right or I could I
could I think he did that in my
interview with him maybe it was yours
that I was yeah because you did and I
was like oh he did it in my brain I was
like oh he did it okay oh he did it oh
my God because you want you know it's
always a thing you one of your
interviewing actors you never asked them
to do Impressions unless I'm
interviewing Jack Black and I just flat
out ask him which I did you might not
even need to ask him he'll just do it he
just does it anyway automatically yeah
or he does like hidden talents and all
this stuff but yeah the fact that he was
out there kind of in a couple of
interviews not just mine but going out
there and being like whoa let's go yeah
it was yeah it was kind of it was kind
of great so he was actually my favorite
I'd never got to you tell me who was
yours um I mean it's hard to like not
look at Mario because he is like yeah so
you're like oh my gosh Mario but I gotta
give it to Keegan Michael key as toad
wow yeah I really really like because I
don't think toad is an easy like
register to have oh my god with his
natural voice yeah so he in an interview
may have been yours she kind of was like
playing with a different octaves voice
and then he finally I'm not going to try
to do toad because I can't I'm not a
voice actor and he hit that pitch and
he's like what if I pushed it just a
little bit more and and I just like
seeing you know actors or creators and
they're kind of get there and they
experiment with different things like
what sticks what does like oh this
doesn't really work oh this really works
but what if I push the envelope a little
bit more and I liked it and because the
voice for toad
it it just sounded so similar to like my
ears to the game but at the same time it
was different yeah but it I didn't have
like a oh
they didn't nail it like I loved I loved
his take on it and yeah toe didn't get
you know that many lines but when he did
it was it was nice he did at the
beginning they were sort of setting up
that he was going to have more of a
journey yeah and then it seemed like it
kind of you know peaked at the beginning
yeah my second favorite very close
second maybe even my favorite was
surprisingly Seth Rogen like I didn't
yeah I didn't expect it I thought no
offense to Jack Black but I thought Jack
Black was gonna steal the whole thing
and Jack Black was amazing and he was a
perfect Bowser and I have a nephew who's
obsessed with Mario and he loves
villains he loved Thanos he just loves
the film which is a little terrifying
but he was like I was like did you like
Jack Black and he was like nobody else
could have been Bowser he was perfect
and he was he was but Seth Rogan as
Donkey Kong and I'm a Donkey Kong girl
like that was my game growing up so I
think I also have an affinity at an
affinity for that whole sequence yeah he
was my I thought he was extraordinary
and I love that they gave him the
quintessential moment moment to do his
own laugh yes that they kind of put
little Easter eggs not within the Mario
games but they almost gave each of the
characters their own little Easter eggs
like I don't know if this was
intentional or not but the Mario Kart
sequence
the Rainbow Road there was almost like a
Mad Max and then Anya's playing furiosa
in the next mad like it was almost like
little things there were some Guardians
like little references for Chris with
the music one of the songs yeah and I
just felt like they gave Seth like let
him have a moment yeah you know and it's
funny because he Seth doesn't do voices
right um so it's his natural voice but
it goes so well with Donkey Kong there's
actually a YouTube edit of somebody
animated
um a Donkey Kong like animation but they
input the lines from Pineapple Express
and it fits so perfect I was like oh he
is the correct casting Choice and then
the laugh I just like is laugh a lot
like I just want to talk to the man
because I can hear him laugh
um and I think again that fits with
Donkey Kong so I really I really liked
it and I liked the the character that
the character also had a little bit of
art
that sequence that whole jungle Kingdom
sequence was by far my favorite and what
I think was a nice touch and people can
correct me if I'm wrong because I know
some of the games I don't know all of
them but Donkey Kong him having that
element of I'm super famous yeah in my
world that that was his he was kind of
like the bratty son of Cranky Kong which
I know wasn't the same as the games
because Cranky Kong wasn't Donkey Kong's
dad I don't think but that they made him
his dad and it's kind of like you gotta
fight my son and he kind of comes into
the ring like with his you know the wrap
up here and I'm here and it's like the
people in the audience are like you
imagine him and I want to see more of
that world because you imagine him sort
of walking I want to know his day-to-day
life I want to know when he walks around
as he's signing autographs probably is
he like what's he doing I loved that
they'd put that element into it where he
was kind of this like you know I'm
trying to think of who it would be like
the equivalent to like the rock or
somebody oh my gosh you know like he's a
superstar yeah he's like a superstar he
can smash he's you know he's anyway I
thought that sequence and that
performance was my favorite yeah and I
really liked you know between that was
essentially his and Mario's first time
meeting and it was you know doing this
this crazy one-on-one battle which it
gave me it gave a little like DK
throwing the barrel because that's like
the the aesthetic of his game but then
it also gave me they didn't really lean
as far into as I would hope so maybe if
there's gonna be a Mario 2 let's go
um they can lean into a little bit more
of like super smash yeah because I was
ready for the character to like beam off
character and then that like off the
screen and then the the you know the
spark of light coming in
um but just watching
DK essentially oh Mario for the first
half yes battle but then we get the item
boxes and Mario really realizing like oh
I can utilize this yeah and it was a lot
of like punching kicking moments and
then we have little comedic moments like
the cat box which I cracked up I was
probably so annoying in that screening
because I just laughed it up I really
just sat there and enjoyed it I did too
I thought I was the only person laughing
because we saw it with a press screening
so my section was actually pretty like
were they I was in the back and I felt
like I was the only person because just
I don't know press it's definitely more
subdued usually than well because we're
taking notes yeah we're interviewing
them and that but yeah I think well that
whole sequence felt like a mini movie
there was a there was a real story to it
it was kind of like Mario for the first
time utilizing his power-ups and that in
the real world practically and not the
obstacle course that peach taught him it
was the first time it was you really saw
him get like
it really set up the stakes in the sense
of you were like at the beginning oh
he's getting so pummeled like how is he
gonna get out of this kind of thing yeah
and just for me seeing the damn barrels
and the levels
I saw it in the trailer and I knew it
was coming but it was just genius
um animation the movie just made me so
happy the animation is so pretty and I
really think they nailed every world you
were talking about different galaxies
different worlds before and even to you
know
um a character who I feel like I wished
had a little bit more of a spotlight but
Luigi when he was you know when they got
separated and they went into they leaned
into a little bit of like Luigi's
Haunted Mansion which I love that game
um so
I I enjoy that they put a little bit of
that that element in there for us
um
but yeah he didn't have a lot to do in
that world and lumily as well they
didn't he didn't have a lot to do I
think that would be one criticism I
would have
um and I know they flipped it where
Princess Peach didn't need to be rescued
it was more um Luigi that had to be
rescued
um and yeah when he sort of walked up
and you know you see the Mansion I was
like oh where are they going with this
this is going to be so cruel they're
actually giving us Luigi's Mansion in
the first movie and now I think that
they could you know obviously they
didn't really delve into it in the way
they could you know they could have next
movie
yeah they could yeah but I yeah I agree
but I think Charlie day he's just he
doesn't have to do anything his voice
sounds yeah
yeah they truly did a great job casting
this movie really did they really did
like and even for peach too because
Peach in the games from what I can
remember don't really speak a lot you
know she's you know the Damsel in
Distress she gets kidnapped by Bowser
and you know save me Mario and
Etc and I think Enya brought a different
a lot more complexity to to Peach than
just a princess who needs help in Saving
her kingdom who's seeking help from
Mario or who needs the rescuing right
and we get a little bit of backstory for
her too it's you know we have this
Mushroom Kingdom all full of toads and
then we have Princess Peach and we get a
look at who she is yeah and then we can
hopefully explore that in you know if
they give us follow-up films
who she is where she came from and then
give us more of that relationship
between maybe her and Mario or whoever
else and I think that'd be a lot of fun
so I think Enya you know with being the
tremendous actress she is brought a lot
of different layers too she'd Peach her
voice as as a voice actress she's very
solid like she just you feel soothed by
her voice she felt like she had a
command of it it wasn't
um
and I like that there was a nice balance
I always go back to the original Wonder
Woman film and I think part of the
reason that film worked for me is
because you had Wonder Woman being a
strong woman but she also was a woman
yeah and she didn't have to try to be a
dude and she and Steve went on this
journey together and they were partners
and whether or not there's going to be
any romantic thing between them and the
future is different but yeah just the
fact that they were yeah she was very
um capable but they didn't I don't like
it when as a female when people hit you
over the head with look how she's like
sort of you know overdo it yeah for the
sake of being yeah she was just she was
in charge and she knew it but she also
knew that she needed help to save her
kingdom and I was like great I loved it
and I think for her to go on the journey
with Mario versus Luigi works as well
because who else is going to be able to
be a better guide than Princess Peach so
I was like this is this is perfect I the
first time I saw the Mushroom Kingdom
oh my gosh wasn't that it and and then
when they walk up to it and I loved the
joke about princesses in another castle
Yeah the Toads were kind of like oh she
got oh she's not here right now it's not
that she needed rescue her right she's
just like yeah they were just protecting
her kind of thing it felt very 20 23 how
people are you know she's not here yeah
people don't answer their door you look
at your little ring doorbell yeah yeah
no yeah that was that was really cute
and then and then the other visual that
was my favorite was Mario being sucked
through the glass tubes I thought the
animation of that and that's a game
reference as well but I thought that was
such a i it's almost like sometimes when
I I love when I watch a movie and I
don't know how they did it yeah when you
go there's so like because we see so
many movies we're like oh I see how they
shot that or I know how they animated
that but I was like wow that was another
level of yeah you know I would love to
hear the animators talk about how they
did that sequence the clear that had to
be really tough so cool and you know
what's what's funny is you know as a kid
growing up playing Mario you know you go
through in the game you just go through
here sound I can't do it um and you come
up the other end you're in a different
level or different world wherever it may
be but in this one because it's Mario's
first time experiencing it we get to
experience it with him and it's not
because it's his first time not the
smooth ride like I thought it was going
to be right just because toad was like
wee let's go and then Mario was like
and essentially getting beaten up by the
pipes and now it was just funny just to
see how he handles the first time being
in Mushroom Kingdom and just literally
being dropped into this this strange
world to I gotta go get my brother I
need to master all these skills
immediately because somebody I care for
immensely is in trouble yeah that there
was a journey because you know in the
very big opening sequence when they're
in Brooklyn and he and Luigi are walking
along the street and he naturally starts
jumping and doing all these little Flags
so I thought at that moment oh they're
gonna make him one of those prodigies
like when he gets to the Mushroom
Kingdom everything's easy he just has
his natural ability that he didn't know
he had like he was always doing that in
Brooklyn but the fact that they didn't
do that and they sort of took him back
to scratch that he had to learn and that
what made him the hero was the fact that
he never gives up yes
yeah yeah and for a kids movie I was
quite moved by it and quite inspired by
it uh so let's talk about your favorite
Easter eggs in the movie oh gosh there's
so many there's so many but I think I'm
partial to the Mario Kart stuff just
because that was the one of the the
games that I always stay up until four
or five in the morning playing with
friends and you're you get mad at each
other because you knock each other out
of first place like I have so many like
to the point where it's like I can't
talk to you for the next hour because I
could have won first and you came in
with your blue shell so it was all the
items that had to do with Mario Kart
like even from customizing the car and
getting that the big a button I was like
yes because you can do that in the games
now like for like in the I think the
very first iteration you couldn't do it
you just got like the car that that
right gave you right
um so little different things and seeing
how the characters would be using their
items whether it be the Red Shell or the
banana peel or the the the blue shawl
the one that everybody hates I really
enjoy seeing that and then it's less of
an Easter egg because I I feel like the
whole movie essentially was like the
entire movie it was an Easter egg which
I loved but the music by Brian Tyler the
music I love it was amazing
so yeah it's like when when somebody
immediately gives you that nostalgia
but it was it was another level it was
very it was a more sophisticated
um rendition or a different a new
rendition but it was familiar enough yes
um and then all of the music like The
you know Bowser's Fury and all the like
this Peach song and I I just think all
everything melded together and clearly
Jack Black said to them I'll do this
movie for you people however I'm gonna
need to sing I'm gonna need this I'm
gonna need to be my Tenacious D self yes
but it was brilliant that every time
that they would show Bowser on screen
and switch worlds they would play metal
music yeah it was perfect it was just so
like like a nice little Easter egg for
Jack Black and for Bowser yeah whose
personality and I like that too I liked
them leaning into the you know why is he
so obsessed with with p with taking over
these kingdoms and going after the
Superstar and then you find out the
reason is he's got this huge crush on
Peach but then being the bad guy that he
is he's kind of like I will give you the
ultimatum you can't say no because you
know we belong together no matter no
matter what uh and and the song was just
like a fun not to like the softer side
of Bowser he's got this hard exterior by
the inside he's just like I just really
want to love Peach I love her I want to
show her and it did work and I think
it's also a choice because it is a kids
movie that they could have had him be a
Thanos type character just pure evil and
we've seen it in so many films there's a
pure evil person but the fact that they
played into Jack Black's
humor and allowing him to sort of be
funny be vulnerable you still hate him
yeah but then he has these moments
and
so I as far as the Easter eggs goes
there's so many there was like I wrote a
lot of them down I like lumos lumos the
little little dark star that was in Capt
captivity along with like yes the cons
and Luigi and I was like oh Mario Galaxy
Rosalina when yeah that's why I was
thinking I was like are we gonna We
didn't get it in this movie but again
hopeful for the second one that yeah we
didn't yeah that was one thing a lot of
people
um wanted to know as if Rosalina would
make and what would make an appearance
yeah
um which she did not it's okay but
Pauline did yeah Pauline made an
appearance as the mayor of New York I
think it was well she was on the TV yeah
my very favorite Easter egg was at the
very end and this came courtesy I'm
gonna reference my nephew again but
before I went to see the movie he's like
if he doesn't take Bowser by the tail at
the end swing him around I'm gonna feel
like the movie sucked and when he did it
because that's the quintessential how he
defeats Bowser and I'm like of course
they were gonna do it but until I saw
that moment that was that I think that
was my chef's kiss that was oh yeah
that's right the ultimate finish yeah ah
so good
um I wrote I wrote some of the other
ones down I mean I just loved I love the
Koopas I'm obsessed with the Koopas it's
not really an Easter egg but the movie
is so full of like I've I've been down
rabbit holes where you watch even the
trailer breakdowns yeah where people
break down all of the little references
but I liked when Mario was playing Kid
Icarus I thought that was really cool oh
that was great at the very beginning
yeah and then let me see if I had oh
Tanuki suit was a nice knot
yeah they found they found a way to I
think no matter what what you're going
to get out of this movie is probably to
what you put into it so if you're a
Mario fan and you know every single
there are people who are like I know
every single game and I watched it a
second and third time and I'm still
finding Easter eggs I mean from what
Mario has on his walls in his room to
everything yes there's there's so many
you can just keep going down a rabbit
hole
um I don't know all of them but I would
say the more you know about the movie
the more you're probably gonna be and
yeah thralled and be able to go watch it
20 million times but the nice thing is
having a casual interest in the games
and having just growing up with it
nobody can go to that and not recognize
somebody yeah somebody or something that
they feel nostalgic from in the games
yeah and speaking of nostalgia like I
thought of my dad the whole time I was
watching the film because he was the one
that showed me Mario he was one that
bought the Nintendo system and my mom
was like what are you doing we're not
having video games in this house and
he's like it's for me and it's true he
put it in his study so like I had very
little access to it but Mario was the
first game that was like Mom approved
for me to be able to like play and I was
at the time I was way too young to
understand how the controller worked and
and like the the hand-eye coordination
was not there
um but my dad would put me in his lap I
have pictures and like would
um play so I would I grew up watching
like the original Mario game
um so just to watch this movie come to
life and think of like how old I am now
and how many iterations of different
Mario games there have been since and
like how my dad would feel watching this
movie and he hasn't seen it yet because
he's not like a movie theater kind of
kind of guy he would prefer to so he
might have to be a little while until he
goes and sees it but when he does like
I'm excited for him to explore the whole
world in like full vibrant color yeah
well the colors are insane yeah um I
thought of my other favorite little nod
and that was the Sunshine Travel Agency
in Brooklyn At the beginning which was a
reference to because I don't play the
game game but the sunshine world is one
that I would I love just because my
worlds too yeah it's just it's just a
pretty World
um let's talk about maybe anything that
fell short of expectations as far as you
were concerned oh okay uh I think for
one I feel like I addressed this earlier
already in our conversation but the the
lack of Luigi and Mario action together
like yeah we got some beginning and end
but because he had to you know he was in
captivity I I just had hope for like a
Mario Brothers team up a little bit more
in this one
um and I enjoy hearing Charlie day so
I just wanted more of that uh or just to
let Luigi do his own exploration yeah
and meet up at the end like I feel like
that fell a little short for me that
that was the one that I was like um I
could have because Mario was all about
his brother and I felt like when they
were
in those cages over The Lava
and the dialogue was just okay like I I
don't know I want
I can't remember but I don't feel like
at any point they really tried super
hard to like break themselves out they
were obviously in distress but they're
like how do how do we do this
um so that's one thing that I really
keep going back to I was like I wish we
had more of Mario plus Luigi in like
second half of the second act to the
final act that and I was really hoping
for like a Mario I was really hoping for
that they didn't they didn't give us not
really but it's okay
yeah I think I I agree with you they I
think they could have
they spend enough time with him yes
they just there wasn't a lot of
exploration in that world and yeah it
was very much I think I feel like maybe
they went to the cages one too many
times with lumiliate talking and I
wasn't sure where they were going with
that and I sometimes wonder too like did
things get cut out right like they maybe
it was a longer movies movie and then
they decided to keep it really simple
and simplify it I'm trying to think of
if anything
I know there was things that bothered me
but I'm trying to think of what they are
now like nothing like I think I
mentioned
I wanted it to be longer yeah I think I
wanted it to be about 10 15 minutes
longer yeah because I think animated
movies for kids can be a little bit
longer yeah they can be a little bit um
yeah when they went back to Brooklyn I
think I wasn't ready I think yeah I
wanted to spend a little bit more time
in the mushroom I feel like that was
actually kind of sudden right like it
was just like everything was happening
once and boom boom Brooklyn impacted and
I was like oh oh we're close to the end
and again and that's when I knew I was
like oh the movie's almost over I don't
want to look at my watch yeah you know
to be like how much time do we have left
because I wanted to stay in that world
for just a little bit longer and it was
so much fun
um I I kind of wished but we already in
a way and this goes hand in hand into
you talking about wanting a longer movie
so we got to explore Mushroom Kingdom
Bowser's home essentially and the jungle
Kingdom but we didn't really I would
have loved to like
kind of do like a not a side quest for
but for a lack of better word just to
another
Mario world that we would have known
just as a quick like
they're seeking guidance from somebody
could have been Rosalina could have been
anybody right could have could have been
Daisy you know or something like that
like that would have been kind of cool
to see just to and that would have taken
maybe 10-15 minutes and then we would
have had like an hour 45 and that still
would have been okay so that's that's
kind of something I was hoping for but I
think what they wanted to do with this
movie is to really flesh out these you
know core characters before we go too
crazy and fully expand because you have
to remember like yes the majority of the
people who are gonna go and see this
movie multiple times are the Mario fans
but there's also you can't like leave
out the people who there are people who
haven't played Mario but you want this
movie to be just as enjoyable for them
and like not too hard too hard to
understand because I've had people ask
me like I haven't played Mario should I
go see this movie I'm like oh absolutely
yes you don't need to know the game it
doesn't alienate you from this like you
know what Mario is they're like oh yeah
like nobody
like everybody knows who and what Mario
is even if they have them play the game
so I think this movie focused on what
they needed to focus on so that we can
if they choose to expand the world then
they can in the follow-up films they are
expanding the world they made
377 million dollars worldwide 204
domestic which the 377
was a record an all-time record for a
animated movie opening it was a five-day
opening because of the holiday weekend I
think Frozen two would have beat it over
five days but it was that was a
three-day weekend but basically it was
a Bonkers Bonkers opening weekend and I
think the nice thing about the world
that they set up is there are so many
places to go yes and there are going to
be more
I have a real wish for the next film I
feel like
they have more than enough to work with
to just do a straight up sequel oh yeah
or they start spinning off before they
start
giving people their own movie before
they start oh where we're gonna do Super
Mario Galaxy for the second one yeah or
you know whatever World they would want
to explore I think there's enough there
because there are worlds that haven't
been fleshed out yeah like within the
story
and I think there's enough they kept it
simple enough Bowser is still around
adorable Bowser is still around yeah
they can have they could even have
Bowser shift and and I don't know if
Donkey Kong and Mario have something and
there's still a little bit of that right
there's yeah there's there's so much to
explore that what I think and I'm going
to reference Marvel again but what
Marvel did so great with the way that
they built their Kingdom
was they did it slow and they had a real
idea of where they were going and I can
see little things that they've planted
in this one where I'm like oh they like
the fact that we don't know Peach's
story yes right that she hints that she
doesn't have a family and she ended up
in the kingdom and the Toads took her in
yeah I'm like they know where they're
going with that story they didn't just
put that story in for nothing they know
what they're building and they have an
idea and I think that's what Kevin feige
did so well with Marvel in the beginning
stages was there was a 10-year plan and
I don't think they need to rush this
they spell it's obviously so much time
and Care making it so detailed and
within the story giving people so much
to to enjoy that I don't I don't think
that they need to rush I don't think
they need to do a sequel and a spin-off
around the same time no and I like what
you said I think having a sequel just a
direct follow-up to this one would be
great you know obviously
um if you stayed for the end credits you
saw Yoshi everybody saw Yoshi or the the
beginning of it so like that's exciting
to see how they're going to put that
into the second film and how that's
going to be introduced
um I would love to actually get the
sequel of that and then we do a spin-off
of whatever character maybe it may be
Mario DK preach Bowser whoever
um and like I I want to see like a full
Saga of the Super Mario Bros movie yeah
I think you know the fact that they
touched on these different worlds and I
heard somebody critique the movie and
say they didn't they wanted to spend
more time on the Rainbow Road or more
time underwater or more time
um in Donkey Kong world and I think
that's
kind of nice because it leaves you
wanting so much more that they could go
back to this whole what they've set up
yeah before they give a full and look
after the sequel
I need a Donkey Kong spin-off yeah
because I want to I want to live in the
jungle Kingdom I want to explore that
world all everybody that we saw wait I
wrote it down we saw cranky chunky Dixie
Diddy funky
you know wow we saw them we I want to
know all about their interactions I want
to know all about their relationships
and I think
Donkey Kong is such an interesting
character that that's the world so after
the sequel I want a Donkey Kong spin-off
what about it and then we can get like
the third movie yeah after that no I I
feel like
out of all the characters aside because
I don't really feel like Mario needs his
like he is the star of his movie so we
don't need a Mario Solo movie but and in
a sense I almost don't feel like we need
a Luigi one yet yes right man for sure
yeah but I think we we flesh out some of
the other characters and Donkey Kong is
a really really good one because
like his story is interesting too
because you know there's a little bit of
like that back and forth with between
him and Craig young which essentially is
his dad in this film
um and like what's the aftermath of all
of this like I don't I don't really need
like a like a prequel uh you know origin
story for for DK like we've established
two years already and we can do
flashbacks and his own spin-off but yeah
I'll establish what's going forward and
that can be the one that Bridges the
sequel movie to the next movie I'd love
that what do you think what do you think
they were doing with the Yoshi why do
you think that was the scene the
post-credits scene well one I think if
they don't add it people yeah because we
only saw in the actual movie we only saw
a quick like flash of like Yoshi's world
and there was I was like oh the Yoshi's
okay bye Yoshi's so um that's definitely
going to be
when
we get the sequel I think
obviously something probably Bowser
breaks out in his full size again and
he's like I'm gonna show Mario that he
you know he got lucky the first time or
something like that
and hopefully then we can spin off the
like hey off planet of this Mushroom
Kingdom we can go elsewhere and that's
where Yoshi is going to be introduced
and that becomes like you know the
partner from Mario yeah and the rest of
the game yeah I think that's how I how
it's gonna happen um yeah I'm trying to
think of who else I mean I think Peach's
story yeah a peach origin story because
they did show you
Baby Peach Baby Mario Baby Luigi in the
in the film so cute a peach or origin
story could be adorable yeah
I want to see peach in Brooklyn
that's okay because yeah and I'd like to
see more of the interaction with the
family because actually they did a very
good job of oh he has this family and oh
you know yeah how his dad feels that you
know yeah yeah I felt the the issue like
the you know disappointment to your dad
and wanting to exceed expectations my
stomach is growling uh I feel like
there is a lot more to be explored but I
feel like if they have put it all in
this movie would have just been too
heavy right so let's have it would have
been first off yeah and they gave us
more than I thought they were they
really did because I wasn't expecting a
whole family Dynamic for for Mario and
Luigi I was just thought they were gonna
be like
I actually had no idea that they were
gonna go that full into like family
dinner and like Mario getting upset and
getting off getting you know up from the
dinner table so I would like to see more
of that and like is the plumber business
you know like booming after he saves
Brooklyn because that make a film a
whole new commercial right or or his dad
you know giving him more pressure he
still doesn't feel like he's
accomplished enough in his dad's eyes
like I don't know but there's a lot of
different angles that we can go for the
next film they could have even I mean
they didn't even have to give us
all the worlds that they did they didn't
even have to give us Donkey Kongs the
jungle Kingdom they didn't have to give
us the Rainbow Road they could have had
a film that was in the Mushroom Kingdom
flash over to Bowser's airship and go
back and forth yeah
they gave us so much they did they did
why do you think the box office
did as well as it did
I think the one is a very well-known
game IP yeah um and I think it speaks to
everybody again if you you don't have to
have play the game to know what Mario is
right so I think it's it's curiosity to
for the non-gamers like okay let me go
see what this movie about for the gamers
I think the answer is pretty you know
obvious it's they grew up with it for
Nostalgia reasons and then there's the
for the box office too so you have
you know me who who grew up very like a
baby watching dad play games so then you
think of families
taking their parents and taking their
grandchildren like to the same movie and
that's going to multiply for this box
office and on top of that Mario is
worldwide Mario is global right
um so it's not so focused on like oh
just domestic opening like everybody all
over the world is going to want to go
and see this film and because there's so
much happening in it with all the Easter
eggs and this and that it deserves to be
seen multiple times so you can catch all
of this stuff and on top of that the run
time is a nice hour and a half so for
families it's really manageable I think
for the kids to to have that attention
on the screen to be like yeah it is
smart in that sense and yeah I think
part of it was I know for my friends
that have kids yeah young kids
the kids just need to see the commercial
and my friends will say oh my my son or
my daughter's really into that they're
really into that and they don't know the
property yeah and there's other films
like trolls that they've been and
there's certain bells and whistles and
visuals that immediately hook kids which
is you know they don't need to know the
story I know they want to go see this
movie I had so many people be like oh my
kids are you know go going crazy to go
see it and I'm so thrilled because I
played Mario as a kid and now I get to
bring them but I think yeah there's
something in the Zeitgeist I'm always
fascinated with how movies do opening
weekend because there's something that
you feel there's like an energy or a
Zeitgeist
um where it just
built this crazy momentum and then I
think despite the score the Rotten
Tomatoes score when the first when I saw
the first few audience reviews coming
out and I'm talking the ones that came
out like at the three o'clock showing on
Wednesday immediately immediately and
those were probably the gamers yes and
when I saw it and I was like okay well
obviously the gamers are gonna really
like it I wonder if it's gonna drop it
all over the weekend nope yeah no it's
just certain things that are Universal
that yeah that people just sit beloved
property character yeah and you know it
makes sense and I think they did a
really good movie and the animation for
illumination that's like top tier
illumination to me yeah and I absolutely
loved it so they crushed it yeah and
actually I looked up
uh
uh video game you have to look up video
game movies that are animated
it's actually the Rotten Tomato score
isn't that low compared to how so many
others have fared so there's something
there's definitely something there so
like in comparison to like detective
Pikachu and Sonic Pikachu is a little
bit higher in Sonic but I'm talking like
when you go back oh there's there's a
you know it actually when you I think we
rank them on our Tomato Meter at the top
um video game animated films and I think
I think Mario was third oh my God yeah
or fourth so you know in the grand
scheme of things
um Wendy this was such a pleasure to
have you please let everybody know where
they can find you oh thank you so much
it was so much fun to get to talk to
Mario and the movie with you uh I'm
going to leave zany you can find me on
the movie couple on YouTube and
um my buy lines at Moviefone and I I've
watched your movie couple in uh videos
and they're totally adorable so people
you should check them out so thank you
so much for joining
um I'm absolutely gonna go watch this
movie again I tried to do it over the
weekend and I didn't have a chance but
I'm gonna go see it again and that 1 30
run time as an adult doesn't hurt me
either I'm happy but I know I can get in
and out but thank you all for watching
the after show and we will see you on
the next one bye
foreign